let's make some delicious fudgy brownies
start by chopping up eight ounces of
chocolate I'm using dark chocolate I
slipped my chocolate into two I'm Gonna
Save the one with more chunks for later
and then I'm gonna go melt this down
should look nice and melty like this
combine some melted butter some sugar
give that a good mix add in two eggs
vanilla extract mix this up and we're
looking for a fluffier and lighter color
add in our melted chocolate that's been
cooled we cooled it down so we don't
cook the eggs mix this into the batter
let's sift in our dry ingredients flour
cocoa powder I'm using dark cocoa powder
and salt sifting your dry ingredients
really helps with getting you a smooth
batter fold this in and try not to over
mix we don't want our brownies to be all
cakey add in the reserved chocolate
chunks fold this in transfer into our
prepared baking dish top with additional
chocolate chunks and she's ready we're
gonna bake at 350 for like 20-ish
minutes 25 if you like a more done but I
like a more fudgy soapy oven and fully
cooled let's cut it up that is
unbelievably rich and fudgy